Speaker 1: OK, let's see if we can just check
in with a couple more people.
Right.
I mean, there's just so much action happening
right now.
Let's speak to Brian from Florida.
Brian, you're on the air, Bryan, with a Y,
importantly.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: I could thank you and, uh, yeah,
Bryan with a Y is very important.
Uh, big fan of your show.
I just have a question like, uh, why so?
Why are you still covering up?
Speaker 1: So why am I still covering Trump?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I mean, he's not the president
anymore.
I get that he has a base, but
Speaker 1: yeah, I mean, so listen, I mean,
I have a clip out about this already.
We're really mostly not covering Trump.
I think this week out of about 50 stories.
We do.
I think like two or three are trump related.
So we're really not.
But it you know, to pretend that the the Republican
Party is no longer Trump in would be delusional.
I would be doing you a disservice.
They just voted to expel Liz Cheney.
It's you know, this is a Trump and Republican
Party.
So to some degree, I have to keep covering
it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, for sure.
But there are tons of stuff going on right
now.
Right.
Stuff going on.
Speaker 1: That's why, again, out of 50 stories
this week, I think two or three had to do
with Trump.
Speaker 2: Cool.
OK, well, maybe I just I watch it, you know,
fairly regularly whenever I whenever I can,
I just put it that way.
Yeah.
And I still it's still a huge, you know, a
big fan of your of your of your channel.
I just think it it's not just you, you know
what I'm saying.
And, you know, you haven't been highlighting
it, but a lot of left wing, I guess you could
label it, is that they still talk about Trump.
And the minute he got the minute Joe Biden
got inaugurated, it was such a big relief.
And, you know, not to get into that, but it
just seemed like people would just fall back
on Trump.
And I still hear a lot of a lot of left people
still talk about him.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, again, I think it's appropriate because
until the Republican Party still seems to
be the party of Trump, and if that's the case,
it's it's hard not to talk about him to some
degree.
But I agree with you that, you know, making
making it or anything, the sole focus when
so many things are going on doesn't make a
lot of sense.
Speaker 2: Even naming I mean, it's labeled
the Trump.
I mean, it's just so many things that gives
power to the like the entity of Trump, I guess,
a trump basis.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know.
Speaker 2: I think would be branded.
Speaker 1: I don't know.
But the thing is, if it's if it's still the
party of Trump, if 70 percent of the party
still thinks Trump won, if two thirds of the
party would follow Trump if he left the Republican
Party, it's not up to us to start calling
it something else.
When, if and when the Republican Party stops
being the party of Trump, I'll stop saying
it.
You know, me, me using different language
isn't actually going to change anything.
It's just not going to accurately reflect
reality.
I can't do that to my audience.
Speaker 2: Yeah, for sure.
That's all
Speaker 1: right.
Are we so we're still we're still on good
terms, right, Brian?
Oh, yeah.
OK, all right.
All right.
Good.
Thanks for the call.
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
All right.
Take care.
There is Brian from Florida.
Love Brian from Florida.
Great call.
All right.
Thank you to everybody that called in.
There are always more calls to take, but at
some point it must end and we will take calls
again very soon